this is a production of Cornell
University
and thank you again for coming so today
I'll be presenting about applications of
multi freight and multi canal models for
genomic selection in cassava and I'm
really grateful to a lot of people who
have like helped me to reach this stage
okay well I'll skip the outline and tell
you a little bit about cassava which is
kind of very exciting to me cassava is
no longer an orphan crop about 263
million metric tons we are produced in
2012 cassava is a starch mission
so we have about 90 percent of drivers
Kappa hydrates and then some tracy's all
that stuff cassava is an out crosser
producing male and female flower and the
interesting thing is even with low
imputes and marginal and still giving
some tangible productivity so it's very
interesting this is the most interesting
to me it's 2016
I guess who were in China and we
collected this information that China
has bought about a billion US dollars
worth of cassava chips and that's very
interesting it's gonna drive market and
I think again the reason is that cassava
starch is very very very appealing to
the food industry so with that I make a
jump now to my introduction mixed models
so I was introduced to nice models by
working with Danny said at dinner he
just walked in and I lent la jolla from
beneath to index so II remember ml has
three servers if s so Verizon very
single candles over by canal we need one
random effect and and it's based on the
EMA gordium the the the second service
is the motor canals over which is in
fact heir apparent DS is based on canal
averaging and then another interesting
solver we have is this mod Street solver
which is based on Lee Seon agar idiom
there was developed by Zhu and Matthews
think 2014 so the interesting thing
about Elam Rama is that it is very
flexible and you can adapt it to various
things and we have actually adapted this
multi traits over to different kind of
models which I will show today and EMM
Renault has in fact been successful in
converting literature so the talk is
structured as chapters in my thesis and
the first chapter we looked at
accuracies of very little motivated
anomic prediction models in african
cassava so our motivation for these was
to understand which models are we to use
for gsm cassava and then the next thing
is to evaluate the breeding values from
these models and see what's going on and
so for these we had data set an
interesting historic data set it was a
multi a multi environment trial data
he was collected from the so-called
genetic game at IIT a button Nigeria and
over a span of about 16 years from 2000
to 2015 we chose these three locations
would be a Johnny button and in fact
these locations are very divergent these
these this is in the rain forest region
this is closer to these and this is like
a semi-arid location so they are very
divergent and
represents areas of cassava production
in the area so we used what we call
clonal evolution trials data only and
cassava breeding clonal evolution trials
where we impose heavy selection on plasm
so cities mostly augmented design with
checks and there are no replications and
this is because of cassava biology we
plant in stakes so you can't get enough
text application so we fit we fit
different sets of models in the first
scenario we fit models using data from a
single environment but multiple year
data and the second we fit multi
environment trials to capture G by E and
we use GBS matrix data to be totally the
genomic relationship matrix from about
one hundred and seventy three thousand
markers so this is a little data on the
trades we're dealing with and some
matrix so this is number of records of
the data we have at different locations
and these are the number of individuals
and we had about three hundred and
twenty four individuals across across
this location so we our target these
trade six trades Sydney we go number of
routes Hector
fresh yield per hectare drama of course
and then lean CNB this is a very
critical trade for cassava and then main
CGM which is a best best CJ pasture that
it's of this take cassava
so in Scenario 1 we fix two interesting
models the first model is the basic G
block model we call UT and this is a
single trade model and then the the the
genomica fed are coming from this
distribution given the genomic
relationship matrix in the same vein we
fit the multi-thread model which is like
this and in this case we have a matrix
of tricks but then the distribution is
different and this is a matrix normal
distribution the matrix normal has a row
covariance and a column covariance and
this is the covariance the capture of
streets by trade genetic variances and
correlations and this this is in fact
the eigen decomposition of this matrix
the genomic referential matrix and it's
a simplification of the algorithm so to
simplify the garden sir
further we use the chronica product and
then transform these to the multivariate
normal distribution and the chronica
helps to get this working but in this
case the Y becomes a long vector of
stock and effects together okay so a
couple of things here is that Y is a
stack of many traits and the X which is
fixed effects comment we use location
trials trials nested within a nested
within locations as fixed and in fact
this the algorithm we use can allow you
to fix different trade different effects
sorry in this experience and this is how
it works
so we fit this model with the air and
f90 package which is the member of the
family of the Lopez 90 program developed
by let's meet mr. Alan Koh and we go
forward again in the next scene
to capture G by E in this data and we we
fit again two models one is univariate
and another is a motivate in this
universe is an interesting model which
is a multicolor model the first color
captures the genomic effect and the
second color captures the clone
bilocation effect and in fact what we do
here is that we use the genomic
relationship matrix for each location
each individual in each location to
capture the genomic part of the
interaction the clone by location
interaction in the multi environment
model we use the same traits in
different locations it's just like the
multi trade model but there are some
subtle differences that one of the
differences is coming from this PG
matrix in this matrix now we capture the
genetic variance of same trait at
different locations in the diagonals and
in the off diagonals we capture
estimates of G by a as the covariances
so the G Vivi's from this ami model
contains both genomic and G by E parts
and ve ve is diagonal by diagonal means
we just allow for variances variants of
the traits error variance of the trade
at different locations and we don't want
correlation between these because there
is no no mechanism degeneres correlation
between a trait at different locations
so to match this to compare this um
model with a me we we join these two
together the genomic part and the and
the interaction part as as DVDs
so to compute the accuracy we fit a
simple model that we call that we call
performance genetic performance model
and this model just is like the the
first beauty model but in in this case
the difference is that it assumes an
identity which means that there is no
relationship between the individuals
concerned and we fit this in different
locations and we think that this
captures T the estimated total genetic
value of the individual so here I show
results and in each block is a different
trait so here is we go AMD is route
number fresh food in each column is a
different location and the first
location is a bad on the next is mocha
and the other one is papaya excuse me
so in red is the prediction accuracy for
the UT model and in green is the
prediction accuracy for the MT model so
we see that in most trails actually that
the accuracies of the empty model at
higher and and in fact we see this in
almost all the traits and what we make
up these I show you a table of one
location and this location is a button
showing the heritability Xin diagonal of
these traits and in the off-diagonal are
the genetic correlations for this trait
so why do we see these accuracies there
we see here that these traits low
heritability traits we have a bunch of
slow heritability traits and then we
have this high heritability and maybe
this medium ones and in fact when you
gently analyze trace of low heritability
with high health abilities and you have
a substantial
correlation going on here we expect that
the multi-thread accuracies will be
better okay so we ship gets to the
second scenario which is the UD and AME
models and just like before we have we
have blocks straights and then columns
and in red is the UE and in green again
is the MA model but in this case we see
that most of them are neck to neck in
fact and just in slides places you have
the AME a little ahead of it higher so
we get some interesting thing in the
genomic matrix of in the G matrix of the
accorded VD here of the ami model and
this is somewhat kind of a description
of what this is and if you think about
for example we go here here in via
jmopod this means that if we select some
lines here in Gubicza we expect about
39% correlated response to selection in
the next environment and and we see this
in all the all the trades and in fact
this gives information on a few of how
to see G by E and then something
interesting again is that you can if you
have several environments you can begin
to cross studies into TPS okay and this
is a table that shows various trends
explained by by by the UE model this is
the clone by location variance is
explained and this is for clone and I
just wanted to point out here that these
new traits have so much G by E variance
is here compared to order
and we know that these traits are so
much affected by the environment and the
same thing goes for these we see here we
have lower correlated response to
selections so in summary what did we get
from these we get that the empty model
of us more accurate reading values for a
single location data and we we see that
this comes from significant significant
correlations and joint analysis with
flow and high heritability traits and we
know that this low rate ability traits
benefit more from this analysis and then
we also see that the MD model and the ue
are not significantly different actually
but we recommend the multivariate
environment for this because we see we
get a lot of information from from
betrayal of both models sorry so
something interesting again coming from
the genetic correlations that I showed
you is that there is good prospect for
concurrent improvement of these traits
in cassava and in fact these are the
most well I would say these are
production traits and kisara religion
important traits we also see something
interesting is that CMD is negatively
correlated with other traits which is
the direction we want them to to be so
in the next chapter I'll move to
comparing selection gains from from
multi trait indices from these models
and it's an it's kind of an effort to
evaluate more the breeding values that
we got from these models so in
literature we see that a lot of models
are usually evaluated by prediction
accuracies there's a few places where
the evaluation is selection gains but in
fact this is because it's not an easy
thing to actually do that they are
predicted
so we actually want to know how these
models perform based on predicted games
and one of the problems is having to
make these models comparable it's not an
easy thing to make even if you have
independent data you should have a
comparable reference framework and you
think about which model do I use to make
the framework is it a multi trato a
single trait anyway we use multi trade
selection indices in this case to
achieve this goal and we compared also
like before the UTM 3ue and emmy models
but we added two other models to these
which explained in the next slide and
these models if you recall the the Yui
model with two canals we we have the
genomic part and the GT part so the UTA
is just capturing the genomic parts and
living out to you if the G pad and this
is just an average of the entire bar and
then we fit another model which is m TM
he which is like a mansion but m e and
entity models this this we think is an
interesting model the two reviewers
pointed out there why don't you do this
it wasn't an easy things to do it wasn't
an easy thing to do though but but but
we fit it's just like the multi-thread
model but in this case we have 18 traits
we organized this trait as straight one
in environment one trait to in
environment one and in that direction so
we had altogether 6 by 3 which is 18 but
then in the arrow arrow part we just use
kind of the the ve de from from the ami
model which is from the sorry from the
empty model which allows traits to be
only correlated in the specific
environment where there
and this model is complex to feed it was
fitting in the Gibbs sampling algorithm
oh definitely
so how did we estimate gains so first of
all we standardized or the trade so that
everybody has the same stat and we used
the same economic weights
these are the weights and these weights
represent 20% increase in vigo that 5%
increase in good number for 5% in Brian
mother that five percent decrease in CMD
min CMD what five percent increase in
yield fresh food and 10 percent decrease
in MC Jia so the index was calculated as
as these so mattress multiplication of
the of the economic weights with the GB
with from each model we selected the top
65 clones from each Motty trait index we
estimated gang as the mean of the index
values of this selected and the trait
games we estimated as the mean of the
Gee Bee Gees of selected individuals so
here we have a plot this is Ruby Agha
this is Mohan this is a button and we
have this box plot I want you to notice
something that in in and all the
locations even here we will have
something like a tie the empty model is
to in better than the UT model but we
see here that the UE model is is doing
much better in in OB aaja and then also
slightly better here on average in in
mocha and slightly better again on
average in at Abaddonn
well let's jump into the trades and see
what was going on so here is Ruby Agha
and each block is a trade
this is Vigo this is route number is dry
matter
this is CND this is fresh yield and this
is a CGM and again they are colored as
the same this is you TM t ue a ue m e
and emptier me I would want to point out
that this U is no is more like what we
do in the next gen is the selection in
this we use in the next-gen program so
we see here in abuja that the UE model
was doing well here and you come to
route number which is a trade today that
has so much influenced by the
environment
eme was from him better and in diameter
DME was on average slightly adamian UE
word UE a word in well so we point out
here in CMD whether you eat UE model was
really dominating others we want this to
go down so this going down is a good
thing for us so this this is the place
that the this model is dominating all
these indices and then for fresh here
it's doing pretty well and and I think
this models rank almost same so we move
to Magua semi-arid region and we see the
mt emei is to a much better here in in
which with we go route number DNT a
misty doing better it does very bad job
here for dry mara again the you the UE
and the UE a dominating for CMD here and
in yield again this empty ami model is
dominating so we move again - ibadan and
again we see the nga me sorry the ami
model is
kind of dominating here on average and
the in roots number is the MTA me here I
can rank these models want to us almost
same and then in again in CMD the youíve
model is dominating in all occasions
so in year three MTA me again and LC GM
bu is doing very bad here actually this
should be going down okay so what do we
see from here we see that some models
have hired DVD stand orders and we kind
of ask a question since we are using
breeding values can we combine reading
values from different models together
well why not if we interested in making
games so we try these we replace the the
breeding value for C MD from MD with
that from Yui and for dry matter and CMD
at n TM e in mobile we replace with Yui
and ue8 and the same here for n TM e we
replace with this and this and then we
move on to see what happened in red is
this composite index I call it and you
see it becomes superior to order or the
ones so I know that there can be a lot
of arguments on why this is not a good
system to evaluate these models there
should be a separate independent
reference to do this but this is just
kind of showing a clue of what is going
on in in this and I think an ideal case
would be to have independent reference
data to to be able to evaluate these
models or jb's
so from what we learn we see that in
accounting for G by E is very important
for making games in
because of G by E we probably need to
use several models we we don't know
which can be good and we also in this
case recommend multi trait models
because they had a lot of information
month variate model sorry they have a
lot of information and this shows good
prospects actually for Kesava
improvement the composite index males
also be beneficial okay so now I make a
jump to something else us type like type
analysis which is mapping traits so we
have an issue in in cassava breeding we
are trying to move towards this
beta-carotene cassava which is sponsored
by harvest clause and so on and we saw
we call it so code yellow cassava but we
have a challenge in yellow cassava the
challenge is that most of most of the
yellow cassava have lower levels of
trimmer actually and and and we need to
understand what is going on in this but
we know already that there is a negative
correlation between ramada and two by
yellowness in cassava so we set out to
understand the genetic basis of these
and here I show a plot this is the white
white cassava path this is the yellow
path and this plot a bullet I brought
from is my Robi which was just plot in
dry matter against yellow coloration so
here you can see clearly that these
populations split so we developed the so
called regional heritability mapping
procedure for cassava and this procedure
is a very interesting application of
linear mixed models so what we do we
divide chromosomes in cassava 18 of them
into windows sliding windows and these
windows are
hundreds nip each week all these
segments so we have this window slide
and true and there is an overlap between
them this overlap is fifty snips I just
sent to 50 snip overlapping with others
and windows so we make a genomic
relationship matrix from these segments
we make another genomic relationship
matrix from the whole genome snips and
this is the correct for background
effect on population structure we fit
two models one no an alternative model
so here the normal model is just like
the G block model using one canal using
all the sleeves but we have but in the
alternative model we fit two canals one
canal for the genomic segment we want to
capture and the second kind of
correcting for background effect so we
use likelihood ratio test to test for
significance of this canal and we plot
these reproduce as Manhattan plots so
what data do we use we use the so-called
genetic data again genetic game data
again but this time only measured from
2013 to 2015 we use a bivariate trait
called pop color which just is sorry a
binary trait we just measures whether
you a yellow or white or maybe off-white
that's the case maybe so we use this to
separate the population into two parts
we use GPS names numbering about 177
thousand and the number of the whites
were 451 and for yellow we're 262 so
phenotypes of course we are from three
locations again
or we corrected these as fixed effects
so
we show the LD between segments its
segments in a chromosome and each color
change is a different chromosome so here
we see see the kind of LD we get we have
this low LD giving us confidence then
when we get associations these
associations be real okay here we see
the me the the this land or spar lengths
of genomic segments in base pairs and we
see that a lot of segments are between
300 plus Cape 200 plus thousand KD yeah
okay so when we plot the results here we
see we see in the first plot is the
white cassava and in the second is the
yellow cassava so we see here we pick up
signals in chromosome one if you go from
four from far from five from 10 from 17
and from 18 and then in in yellow we
pick up only for chromosome 1 and so
bear in mind here also that we have like
very little sample size so what next we
do we try to see whether we can extract
some information from the genome by
doing candidate gene analysis and we
extracted information on 500 KB flanking
each side of the heat we had will show
later the choice of this is 500 KB and
based on literature review we were
seeing two families coming up all the
time and this this is
glycosyltransferase ease and beginning
deeper into these is like carbohydrate
enzymes of which starts in DC sucrose
synthesis and so on and so forth in
there
and we see another family of serine
threonine kinases and and these these
family regulatory protein kinases we
also see in vertices but neutral and
acid and some other plants literally
regions so we also looked on literature
and we saw that this air entraining
kindnesses already have transgenic
studies which i am getting in starch so
before I go on I want to point out that
that our goal was not really to say that
this gene is what is causing this but we
kind of think that these genes may be
tagging regions which are very
interesting for try memory in cassava ok
so how did how do we validate these then
we performed a validation we performed a
validation for these are in training
kindnesses we went to the genome and we
grabbed everything called serine 20
kinase or look like it and we extracted
about twelve twelve hundred genes we
encode it to about 7,000 slips and we
used an independent population which was
the progeny of the genetic game hundred
genetic and parents to validate these
change excuse me we also took randomly
genes from from from the genome about 7
7 2004 about 7,000 snip as control for
this now for these for this we we fix
this to canal model again in the fest
canal is this target which is disorient
run in kinases and in the second is
every retain every resonate in the
genome not ticks and we get prediction
equations for this
okay so we do this as well for all that
other we have we had this this site on
paper which reported cassava genes
involved in stock biosynthesis so we
took those genes excuse me an uncaught
them to snips record em cassava stagings
we also extracted all things called
genes in the rh in the significance
regions we had and this gave rise to
about 2300 snips record in region genes
now based on literature we had these 53
lists of genes that we saw that we could
be implicated in starch and we also got
these and anchored them to sleeps about
400 snips
we got another 53 randomly just a
control for these and then we went into
this region and said oh well let's get
those those genes that I in this region
that are not reported in literature just
to check what is going on and we also
anchored them to about 300 something
plus tips so we used these as well in
the same methodology we use for the SNR
case so here we show the prediction
accuracies for the snacks for 7,000 plus
genes it was up about 50% of the
prediction accuracy we get from the
entire snips in the genome so orders
were about 20 something plus percent and
and the random part for for the snacks
was about half of what the snacks heart
so interestingly here when when when I
do the anchoring of these names I find
out that all the time the same names
come up again and again which means that
we are really talking something
individuals
another thing we did is that we we kind
of since this insight on has already
published this James we wanted to see
which is to with which in our region
that intersecting with these ones that's
I don't pick up and we so for genes two
of them one is an acid in vertex when
it's a neutral invitation think so and
there's this forceful glucose isomerase
and an interesting one the fructose
bisphosphate
aldolase so a quick search on these
shows that Monsanto has a patent pending
on this so again want to point out that
we are not we are not searching for
functionality of these genes but we are
tagging regions in the genome that may
be implicated in Andromeda so this is
just a plot showing all these genes we
had and the regions where we kind of saw
what was going on so I I don't see very
much okay and this is in chromosome one
where we had top hits and the proximity
of different genes that we saw in we
selected as candidates so how do we
validate the the rhm procedure itself we
use the so called had a causal snip
methodology so we move into the genome
we select five adjacent segments by
random and on the third segment we
choose a snip by random and inflate the
variants of the trade fall to about 10%
by adding effect and we make G matrices
for each each of the segments but when
we come to the third segment we remove
that sleep that we used for inflating
the the variants phenotypic variants
with only several times to see what was
going on
so this gave a clue on the span of our
candidate gene analysis because we could
pick up genes about two segments we
could pick up effects about two segments
away from from the from the place where
we added this effect so we saw that the
the HM was a good procedure for
polygenic traits and in this analysis we
picked out that 102 times out of two two
and six we pick the effect that we added
and this was about 47% power of
dictation from Association and and we
think that would increase sample size
will probably benefit more so in summary
the other term is informative for
mapping complex traits genomic segments
may be employed in breeding there needs
to be some research to do this and we we
see that there is good prospect for
improvement of crime and I especially
quite casaba and then gerrymander as
well is a polygenic traits okay so in
case you have nothing yellow cassava
this is how it looks and this is white
cassava okay so I move on to the to the
next chapter which is moving away moving
on from the region of heritability
mapping so one trait I'm trying to map
two traits at a time and in this case we
want to see how to trace our co
inherited together and yeah we use dry
matter again the yellowness which is
wood color and then we also use fresh
food in some trials that they call high
stockpiles so our motivation is to see
how dry matter and this yellowness are
inherited together and again to see
whether we have like prospects of
developing yellow cassava
so how does this go the other CHM
procedure starts by so by fitting I
would point out here that the ideal
procedure should have been exactly what
we did for the regenerate ability but in
my various model but we tried to do that
without success because I cream probably
we have less so much less today we could
not estimate it so big models were not
converging so what we did was to look
for another procedure to do this and
this is the procedure so we fitted by a
very developed model where we use the
empty model as we showed before we use
them principal components in in the
fixed effect part and before we did this
actually we brought out these 10 pieces
and we regress them to to dry Mara for a
start and for white we didn't see much
value for for the pieces they were not
significant but for yellow we saw that
these 10 pieces were explaining about
23% of variation going on so was it was
essential to toward that so
after fitting this bivariate model we
move forward immediately to calculate
slip effects from the model and and this
this is done by very much by animal
breeders so-called slip lock and just
back solve using the estimates that we
got for the billion values the genomic
relationship matrix inverse the Mikami
trees and this mattress may be used to
probably with snips if you are
interested in that
so after solving for sleepy felts we
divided the genome into on each
chromosome into three fairly poor parts
the mean of each segment was about it in
megabase approximately so what we did
was we collected so-called genomic
segments values from these excuse me and
genomic segments values where where the
Mikami trees for this segment were in x
the snip effects in this segment way so
this genomic segment values were
calculated for both traits and and then
to find to find to get a correlation for
genomic segments correlation we just
correlated this genomic segment for the
two traits were interested in so in fact
this is this is a genetic correlation
because we are correlating sort of this
is the proxy looks like looks like a
billion value okay so we did this for
two traits we're interested in joining
Manta and B durometer and fresh fuel and
so on so what later did we use we use
the same data we were using for we used
for the air hm
we applied these to the same populations
again white yellow and in this case we
also joined them together we call yellow
plus y okay so we applied also for dry
matter and unfresh huge in so-called
high starched white trials and these are
trials that had high levels of dry
matter and and and good yield and they
were they were planted sort of to
understand when best to harvest and one
one set of harvests was done twelve
months after planting and the second set
of harvests was done 14 months after
planting so we plot this segment
correlations genome-wide to see what's
going on and excuse me
then we also tried to say that when
these segment correlations are going in
in the direction that the breeder wants
then they are favorable for for what you
are looking for we use so-called
residuary sampling for significance
testing okay I show here plots each bar
represents a segment change of color
represents another chromosome and this
is for white and we see that most of the
segments are in the in the positive
direction and in yellow in yellow we see
that most of these segments are going
towards the negative direction this is
for white mixed with yellow or we see a
mixture of what is going on okay so we
see seventy percent of the segments and
white were favorable and in fact from
the bivariate model we saw that genomic
the trait rates correlation was 0.14
which indicates progress can be made
using a multi trait index so we move
over to yellow which is more interesting
and we see that each 1% of the segment's
were unfavorable and the whole genome
genomic relations where negative zero
point three indicating that develop in
yellow cassava could be challenging so
interestingly this doesn't happen in the
South American gem plasm so sabalos has
has this publication and has been saying
that just a recurrent selection was
doing very well for both in South
America
okay so we argue here
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu